- Good afternoon and welcome to re:Invent.
Imagine tracking
a developing hurricane
in the Atlantic Ocean.
Many lives at stake.
As coastal communities
prepare for the impact,
behind every forecast, behind
every evacuation order,
behind every decision that saves lives,
there is massive amount
of computational power
that is at work.
Today, along with my esteemed
colleague David Michaud
from National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration
and Rayette Toles-Abdullah from AWS,
we will explore how
high-performance computing
is evolving from
traditional supercomputers
to AI-led forecasting,
transforming the way in
which we predict, track,
forecast dangerous weather
events that impact our planet.
The convergence of
high-performance computing
and artificial intelligence
is an evolutionary technology.
However, it is revolutionizing how quickly
and how accurately we can
respond to very dangerous events
and therefore save more lives.
We're excited to take you
through this journey with us today.
Our presentation is gonna
be organized as follows.
First, let's talk about
what the market is doing in
terms of this convergence of AI
and high-performance computing.
According to Hyperion
Research, back in 2023,
the HPC market was about $37 billion
and it grew by 24% in 2024.
We expect the numbers to
be even higher in 2025.
By 2028, one-third of the HPC market
is expected to be on the cloud.
And by 2029, the converged
AI and HPC market
is expected to be $49 billion.
That is huge validation of the market
by some of the early
results that we're seeing,
and also,
it's kind of following the innovations
like agencies like NOAA
are actually coming up with
and executing with HPC at scale.
So then I will invite
David Michaud at that time
to come up to the stage,
and he will do a deep dive
into a NOAA case study.
He'll talk about NOAA's mission.
He'll talk about the
important work that they do,
how it impacts lives,
and how massive amount
of computing at scale
is used at NOAA to do
various mission outcomes.
Then Rayette Toles-Abdullah
will come to the stage.
As a Principal Architect
at AWS, she's been leading
the capability development
and service development
for supercomputing and other
cloud opportunities at NOAA.
She will do a deep dive
into these architectural capabilities
that power NOAA's missions.
And then finally, I will
come back to the stage
and I will discuss some
of the new investments
that AWS has committed in this space,
as well as give you a couple
of additional examples
of innovation that we're seeing
in the converged HPC and
AI space in the cloud
by some of our other partners.
So with that,
I would be honored to have David Michaud
join us on the stage.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name's Dave Michaud
and I work for the
National Weather Service.
My role at the National Weather Service
is essentially responsible
for managing the operations
of the networking that
we have, enterprise-wide,
all the supercomputing,
all the data dissemination systems,
and also, support locally
for all the national centers
that we have in College Park, Maryland.
I've been with NOAA for about 30 years.
It's my life and my
passion, so I'm very excited
to be here today to talk
to you about what we do.
So first, a little bit about the mission
of the National Weather Service.
So oftentimes when I talk to people
about the National Weather Service,
they don't really realize
the diversity of what we do.
A lot of people think about,
okay, what do I need to
wear the following day?
Do I need to bring an umbrella?
We're much more than that in
the National Weather Service.
We have a very diverse mission.
Our domain space covers anywhere
from the entire Atlantic
Basin to the mainland US
to the entire Pacific Basin
in the Northern Hemisphere
in terms of the domain and
scale of what we're forecasting.
And the breadth is astounding.
So we do everything from
the surface of the Sun
to the bottom of the sea.
So we'll monitor the activity
on the surface of the Sun
and forecast electromagnetic
interruptions or storms
that are produced through
coronal mass ejections
and monitor those as
they approach the Earth.
Again, we have the
traditional forecasting,
but then we also have,
like Mickey mentioned,
the tropical forecasting with
the National Hurricane Center
and watching those storms.
Aviation weather.
Again, the entire Atlantic
and Pacific Basin.
When you think of aviation,
we're producing data that's helpful
towards having the airlines calculate
flight efficiency and how
much fuel to put on planes.
Every pilot needs to have
a certified weather brief
before they take off,
and all of our data and forecasts
feed those sorts of mechanisms.
We have tsunami warnings and
we monitor seismic activity
and those impacts on
the surface of the ocean
and what impacts those would
have as they approach land.
And fire weather,
we have actual meteorologists that reside
and are embedded with the fire chiefs
at the site of forest fires and wildfires.
So there's many more pieces
that I didn't hit on.
And one last piece, the
Ocean Prediction Center.
So when you think of the
Ocean Prediction Center,
think of all the economic impact
of all the vessel traffic
traveling across the ocean,
and these massive storms that come
creates the need for ship avoidance
to circumvent or move around the storm.
And so we're really focused on life safety
and the economy there.
So we operate across the United States,
anywhere from America Samoa,
to Hawaii, to Guam, to Alaska,
Puerto Rico, the mainland US.
We're really embedded in a
large number of communities
across the United States.
We have 122 forecast offices.
Those are probably what you
would traditionally see as
or recognize as like a
weather forecast office.
But we also are embedded with the FAA
in air traffic control centers,
providing some decision support.
We have forecast river crest
and the river rise and falls and flooding.
We have specialty national centers
that are looking at unique
kind of niche type of weather.
And then a water center and
looking at the hydrology.
So we're really geared to
be out in the community
with the people who need
to make those decisions.
So today, we're gonna talk
about high-performance computing
and the associated workloads
and how we generate a large
amount of forecast information
that helps with forecasters
producing the forecast
and the forecast process.
But I don't want you to lose sight
from a mission perspective
that that's the only thing that we do.
Forecasts are one piece
of what we produce.
But we've really been focused
over the past decade or so
on making sure that we're working
with decision-makers in
the community to understand
what the impact of the
weather is going to be.
So what do I mean by that?
So give you an example, right?
I'm from Washington, DC.
If we have the slightest bit of snow,
that wreaks havoc on traffic
and that's a massive impact, right?
Where I grew up in New Hampshire,
we could have probably a foot of snow
and people would still
be out moving around
with ease, right?
So impact wise, different places
have different tolerances
for different weather
and different weather types of events.
So we're really focused
on delivering the forecast
and making sure that we're
providing a risk assessment
to those decision-makers in the
community that are providing
those life-saving sort of
direction to the community.
So like evacuating for a hurricane
or closing highways
and so on and so forth.
So we're really based.
What we're really looking to do
is create that trust relationship
with the community decision-makers
so that when things happen,
we don't have to learn
who we're working with.
We have that trust relationship
so that we can just move on the dime
and get those warnings out.
Right, so high-performance computing.
So let's talk a little bit about that.
So in my career, when I look at this,
what gets me excited about
high-performance computing is,
it's one of those areas where
any sort of improvement in
high-performance computing
or technology with
directly correlates to improvement
in the mission performance.
So we see improvements
in high-performance computing capacity
or the way our software works
and the efficiency on
high-performance computing.
That results in better advancements,
more accurate forecast,
higher integrity science
that's going out to our
forecasters to allow them
to perform the mission better.
So really that direct correlation
in improving HPC with
improving the forecast,
which then improves those
trust relationships.
So let's talk a little bit,
we talked about the mission, right,
and the diversity in the mission.
The way in which we
operate within the mission
provides certain constraints
for the requirements and
how we operate the HPC
and how we think about our workloads
and the HPC environment.
One of these metrics that we
chase is product timeliness.
So on a daily basis, we have
a cycle of models that run
and they run everywhere from
every hour to every six hours.
I'll show you in a bit what the diversity
of that workload looks like.
But it's very time-driven
and cyclical in nature.
So you can imagine for
a landfalling hurricane,
there's a certain cadence
where our forecasters
have to interact with decision-makers
and those decision-makers
are looking for updates
and people in the public
and there's a certain
timeliness and rhythm to that
that creates a certain level of trust.
So from a product timeliness perspective,
we create 14 million products a day
out of our supercomputer.
And we look at each one of those
and then we judge ourselves to say, okay,
was it produced within 15 minutes
on average on any previous day?
If it is, we're good.
If it's not, we kind of check
a mark against ourselves
and we reduce our timeliness
numbers and stats.
So we try to achieve
99.9% on time delivery.
I think we have a metric of 99%,
but we really achieve on a
regular basis about 99.9, 7,
99.98% on time delivery on a daily basis.
We'll kind of move on and
just keep that in mind
in terms of the timeliness.
The way in which we generate
and architect our solution,
we have two high-performance
supercomputers
that are about 14 petaFLOPS each
or about 40,000 cores per system
that run in different power grids,
one on the East Coast,
one on the West Coast.
We're able to switch operations
between those within a 10-minute period.
So I can move my entire operation
of forecast operation in 10 minutes
from one system to the next
and with no real issue.
So that's the type of
availability and data movement
that we're looking at on a
regular basis with our systems.
Let's talk a little bit about workflow.
So,
a modeling system,
generally, we have data
that moves into the system,
and so we'll stream on a consistent basis
billions of observations a
day into our supercomputers.
So we'll stream it,
one feed into our operational
primary supercomputer.
We'll have a separate parallel feed
into our backup supercomputer.
And then when the time cut-off
comes to generate a forecast,
we'll dump that data out,
we'll quality control that data,
and then we'll run what
we call an analysis state.
So we essentially use
a little bit of magic
through the physical-based forecast models
to look backwards at
the observational data,
run it ahead three hours in a forecast,
recheck it with some data,
run it ahead three hours,
recheck it to its data,
and then recheck it and
do a final analysis state.
And that gets us to an
atmosphere that's very continuous
that the model recognizes, right?
So you can imagine
in the real world with
all the data observations,
it's not always continuous
and even where we have
an observation point
at exactly every data
point that our model has,
so we have to kind of reconcile that
through a data-analysis process.
And then we run a model forecast,
which will go out into the future.
So we have some forecast
that'll run a few days into the future.
Our global models will run
16 days out into the future.
And then we have other models
that will run two weeks.
And then a coupled climate analysis system
that'll run nine months out.
And then as the model's running,
we need to output and prepare,
dump that model memory out
in each time step out to
kind of post that information
out to a file format
that people can download
and look at and our
forecasters can look at.
And then we have a certain
amount of post-processing,
whether it be statistical post-processing
or just adjustments to the
model or adding derived fields.
We have post-processing.
So the interesting part of this
from an overall workload perspective is,
as you can see, we have certain
parts of the forecast model
that require a large amount of cores
that are massively parallel, right?
So our global forecast model
will require about 25,000 cores
over an hour and a half period
to operate a physical-based model.
Our model analysis will be quite similar.
But then we have a lot
of serial post-processing
that runs around these jobs.
And the way that we currently
construct our architectures,
we have 40,000 of the
same kind of HPC cores.
Some will have higher memory than others.
But we have a lot of processing on there
that's really not HPC
per-se type of processing,
but it runs on our HPC because
it needs to be in proximity
to the data where we run it.
So this kind of presents
an interesting use case
when you start to look at cloud
and the flexibility that you can get
with the various types of instances
versus trying to forecast ahead
when you're buying an on-prem system
about exactly what the
architecture should be
and what exact balance should be
with the multiple-core workloads
versus the serial workloads.
And this is what our
production suite looks like.
It looks like a mess, right?
There's 80 different models.
We have it all scheduled
and it's a bit of a Tetris
puzzle to fit everything in.
But you see the peaks and valleys
generally four times a day.
So if you look at the bottom of the scale,
that's a 24-hour period
from zero Greenwich Mean Time
to zero Greenwich Mean Time.
And each one of those layers
represents a different type
of model workload that we're running
that's layered on top of each other.
So where this gets kind of interesting is,
okay, we have a timeliness metric.
In general, on a daily basis,
things run pretty smooth.
Everything works out pretty well.
Certain days, you might
have a glitch in the system
where your workload might get backed up.
So on an on-prem system
when your workload gets backed up,
we have to do a bit of traffic control
because you can only peak so far
on your on-prem system to catch up.
So oftentimes to catch up,
you may have to load-shed certain models
or certain model cycles
to make that workload work.
Whereas if we were to
contemplate a cloud environment,
that could mean a quicker catch-up cycle
because we could burst differently.
So these are the types of
things that we're looking at
when we're trying to weigh
the benefits of working
with an on-prem versus
a cloud sort of setup.
And just as a side note,
from an AI perspective,
there's a lot of talk about
these inference models,
which we'll get to in a
bit, a bit later here.
You know, it's interesting
when you look at the inference models,
it's really easy to generate
these niche kind of bespoke AI
models that have a specialty.
One might be your standard
global forecast model.
One might be geared towards
tropical forecasting.
Another might be geared
towards a certain domain space,
or you name it, right?
You could get into hydrology
or different things.
And so in a production environment
when you're trying to run
things on a routine basis
and also manage the implementations
that go into operating
a system this reliably,
you could really easily get
yourself into a situation
where you're running so
many different models
that it becomes a bit of a mess
from a change-management perspective.
So as we look at AI, it's exciting,
but I think from a
change-management perspective,
it's an interesting thing
to think about as well
in terms of,
okay, we're gonna have
like 500 models to manage.
Or are we gonna focus
more in gaining integrity
in a lower number of models?
All right, so what I showed
you in the last slide
was the general layout
of the modeling suite,
and that's the bulk
kind of regular, routine,
scheduled work that we have.
So you have kind of 80 different models.
They're all dumping data.
They're all doing their initial
state to the atmosphere.
They're all forecasting into the future.
They're all posting data
and they're all kind of
stacked on each other.
But we also have some
other different workloads
that lend well
to a more kind of on-demand
elastic environment.
One of those is tropical storm prediction
or hurricane storm prediction.
So we have in our
production suite right now,
reserved slots in our
production environment
where we can run up to 12
different hurricane-modeling runs.
So you see each of these yellow boxes
represent the domain of
that particular model,
and that model moves
with the storm itself,
and it's using the global
model for boundary conditions
as it's moving through.
So we can run up to 12 of these
in our operational
environment at any given time,
four times a day.
The problem there is
that we have to reserve
that sort of compute capacity
from a production perspective
to be ready anytime we
need to run those storms,
which means that that's
space on our system
where we can't otherwise expand
the bulk kind of production environment
that I showed in the slides before.
So this is an interesting case.
So the other interesting
piece of this as well
is that when we need to run the models,
we need to spin them up quickly.
So we can't wait around for
the environment to spin up
when we need it.
It needs to be there when
we need to start running it.
So that's another kind
of interesting piece
in architecting the workload
with these sorts of on-demand runs.
We also have development workloads,
which I like to call like
surge development workloads.
So we have our developers working
on constant improvements in the models,
but then there are also cases
where you might want to look back 30 years
at the observational data
and apply that to the latest
technology with the models
and create what we call
a re-analysis data set.
So you're using the current model
to fit it to a continuous
sort of atmosphere,
fitting it to the grid
to make it nice and neat and tidy.
And you're doing that
going back 30 years and you're
doing four forecasts a day
for 30 years moving forward,
which creates a massive amount
of computational workload needed.
But we don't need to do that all the time.
That's an example of a surge workload.
Another example might be
taking all of that
numerical weather prediction
kind of physics-based model and
applying that to an AI model
and training the model to
do that sort of workload.
So it's kind of an example
of a one-time surge, right?
And so on a on-prem environment,
you really have to either
reprioritize your workloads
or you have to go get more money,
take the time to provision that,
get that on the floor,
and then maybe like
six, eight months later,
you're able to start
running your workload.
So that's an example of
development surge workloads.
Shifting gears a bit, this is newer to us
is these AI workloads,
in particular, the inference workloads.
So the things that we run
operationally in production,
we're experimenting with these.
We're in the process of
getting those running
in real time as we speak.
And so currently, we have
a GraphCast-based model
that's trained with our
global forecast model.
And there's two types of
models, modeling systems.
You could have a deterministic system,
which means you make a single model run
out from one initial guess field.
Or you can run it in an ensemble,
which means that you take
an initial guess field,
you perturb it slightly,
and then you run it out into the future.
And what that does is it helps us
with uncertainty calculations, right?
So if you look at a suite
of 31 different forecasts
starting from slightly
different initial conditions
with the same model,
that gives you an indicator
of the type of spread in the forecast
that you could have in the future.
So we have inference runs
that run out to 16 days.
So I told you earlier
that a run like this on
a physical-based model
would take about 25,000
cores for an hour and a half.
This model with just a handful of H100s
can run in seven minutes.
It's a game changer, right?
And our global ensemble
forecast, very similar in nature.
So we're very close to running these
in real time operationally.
We're pretty excited about that
and we're embarking on this mission.
So kind of a word of caution,
though, from an AI perspective
versus physical-based models, right?
Are we gonna go out tomorrow
and just switch straight to AI models
and do that straight from observations?
No.
No, it's a bit of a
codependency, at least for now.
So we need physical-based models
to train the AI models,
statistically-based model,
and then we can run those really quickly
from an inference perspective.
So the model runs that we're talking about
are performing in a very
similar performance level
to our physical-based models,
but just keep in mind
that those are trained
off of the physical-based model.
So that's a codependence that we have.
So we still need significant resources
to run these re-analyses or
these large training data sets
with the physical-based models
to train the AI-based models.
But it's an interesting context, right?
So now from an operational perspective,
you saw the amount of compute
capacity that we needed
to run our physical-based
models on a regular timeframe.
Now think about that with
a bunch of inference runs
that run in seven minutes
versus an hour and a half.
It really changes the nature
of how we think about our
high-performance computing.
And even those inference runs,
for one, do those scale really,
are they really like kind
of the true HPC or not?
So we're kind of trying
to figure that out.
Another interesting aspect of this,
it's something that we're
trying to figure out is,
what's the impact in terms of moving
that data out to the public, right?
I'll give you some statistics in a moment
about the type of data
movement that we have.
But now you're going from outputting
a large amount of data over
an hour and a half period,
with a physical-based model,
to dropping that same amount
of data in seven minutes.
Right.
And from a customer perspective,
they're all expecting that data
to be out and to be available.
So now you have a bit of a
data streaming issue, right?
So you have a lot of customers looking
for the same exact data at the same time,
and all of that's compressed
in a seven-minute period.
That's not really fun to think about
from a data distribution perspective.
The other piece of this as well is,
just looking at the
advancements of these models,
it's really fast paced in
terms of advancements, right?
But the other issue we have is
that the integrity of our data
and the scientific integrity
is super important.
So there's a large validation process
that we have to go through
before we implement a model.
You want to look back
retrospectively to understand
how these perform in different seasons.
If you're updating a
hurricane model, for instance,
you might want to run that
on 90 to 100 different storms
to make sure it's verifying.
You need to make sure
that if you're improving the troposphere
or the mid-latitudes,
you want to make sure
that you're not impacting the tropics,
which would then impact the performance
of hurricane runs and so on.
So this pace of advancement
in the model improvements,
we have to kind of come to grips with,
adding potentially more automation
and insight into the validation
of those models as well
to ensure that we have
the scientific integrity,
and that's a challenge for us.
All right, just gonna
finish up real quick here
on data dissemination, out.
So this is, not sure if a lot of folks
understand the type of
data that we produce,
but we'll send out about
12 to 15 terabytes a day
and make that available to the public.
We'll serve out about 300 terabytes a day,
so about 10 petabytes, 11
petabytes a month of data
that we're streaming out.
And you can see what these
model implementations
as we get to higher resolutions.
It's not a steady amount.
We have to plan and plan
for growth in that as well.
So we offload about 50%
of that data distribution
to content delivery services.
About 50% of that will stream out
from our on-prem systems that we have.
From a web kind of services
or an API-based perspective,
we get a little over a billion
hits a day on our services.
So it's pretty tremendous for us.
And about 80% of those we offload
through content delivery services.
But it's not just that on a steady basis.
Our load will change based on
what we have going for weather.
Hurricane events,
snowstorms, tsunami events.
So this is an example of a
tsunami case that we had recently
where there was an earthquake,
the coast of Russia,
and that created a large amount
of warning and advisories
for tsunamis across the basin.
And we typically get about two
and a half million hits a day
on our web services for tsunami.
In 12 hours, that surged
to about a billion hits.
So that's just a good example
of how we have to be ready
to surge as we move through.
So now I'd like to hand it off to Rayette.
We'll go through some of
the more practical aspects
on the technical aspects on the cloud.
Thank you.
- Thank you, thank you.
So welcome again. My name
is Rayette Toles-Abdullah.
I started supporting NOAA
as their Solution Architect in April 2020.
I was excited to become
someone who's supporting such
a wonderful mission at NOAA
to help save life and property.
Certainly took it seriously,
as you can imagine.
And also, David might not know it.
I'm a NOAA employee who sits at AWS, okay?
That's what we have going on there, right?
To explain NOAA's journey with HPC here,
we started off early 2020, late 2020,
to start to look at benchmarking
some of their models
that they ran on-prem,
in the cloud, right?
We started looking at proof of concepts
and actually porting in
their MPI applications,
which proved to be the longest clip
for getting this done.
Once we got the benchmarking done
for models such as GFS, GEFS,
things of that nature,
and getting the metrics
and stringent information that we needed
for how those models
will run in the cloud,
we certainly were in a place
where we started to talk to AWS partners,
some of our force multipliers
that I'm gonna get to in a second
to help grow their offerings at NOAA
for their scientists
and their researchers.
We flattened a learning
curve along the way, right?
There's a bit of a black box
for some scientists and researchers
who are doing HPC in the cloud.
So we set up enablement sessions
to help everyone understand
how this works in the
cloud and how does it look?
There's less knobs for you
to be turning in the cloud,
which, you know, we've
been able to do on-prem
and found to be unnecessary as well.
We work with our HPC specialists
to help enable that as well,
kind of a unshameless
plug for Aaron Buscher,
who's the HPC specialist who's
not here today to help us,
to actually enable
what we see now at NOAA in
the cloud in terms of HPC.
So there's two offerings at NOAA
that they offer their
scientists and researchers.
In the cloud, in AWS,
they could either run their
self-managed HPC clusters
themselves,
build up the clusters,
interconnect those clusters,
have their head node
and their compute nodes
as they do on-prem,
or they can leverage the
HPC-as-a-Service offering
that they have there.
In that case, we partnered
up with Parallel Works
and GDIT as the prime
to basically provide
a unified, simplified interface
for scientists to run their jobs.
I'm gonna get to that in a second, right?
But either way, the
architecture looks the same.
NOAA standardized on
purpose-built HPC EC2 instances.
These are Hpc7a, 6as.
And introduced at Super
Compute '25 and 2026,
Hpc8as will be released, right?
So they standardized on that.
These are tightly-coupled
clusters as they are on-prem.
So cluster placements groups
can be used so that those clusters are
in close proximity to one
another, right, in AWS.
They standardized on using
Elastic Fabric Adapter.
This gives you
sub-microsecond connectivity
between the nodes that we have
as cluster nodes as you see on-prem.
They standardized on using FSx for Lustre
as the file systems that
give them high latency,
low throughput with their storage system.
But key to that is also the ability
to integrate natively with S3
to import and export data.
Meaning they don't have to
have that expensive storage
consistently, persistently in the cloud.
They can also export that data,
export the data that
the models have output,
and actually do
post-processing with that data
or future analysis with that data from S3,
less expensive object storage
instead of having that persistent
FSx for Lustre storage.
And then, like David was saying,
after their runs are done,
this cluster is basically gone.
It's terminated and they
move on to the next job
that needs to be ran, right?
Some of the on-prem
workflow capability exists.
They still use PBS for job management.
They still use Slurm,
or you can use AWS Step
Functions and Lambda Functions
to kind of handle that
workflow management as well.
But they tend to like to
stick with some of the tooling
that they use now on-prem
for workflow management
and job management.
So going to the HPC-as-a-Service offering,
this was key
to enable the scientists
and researchers at NOAA
to, one, accelerate research
to operations, right?
They have a simplified web portal.
They just go into the web portal.
They select, I need this many cores,
I need this much memory,
I need these EC2 instance types,
I need this type of storage,
and they actually run their jobs.
So what this do is it abstracts
the scientists and the researchers
from worrying about the
configuration of clusters
and how they get the network going
and how they are able to tweak the knobs
for the configuration
in the backend using
infrastructure as code.
Basically, from what they're selected,
they get deployed an entire
cluster to do their jobs, right?
And those jobs really run
at performance capability that
David talked about earlier.
For example, when he was talking
about the hurricane
analysis forecast system.
Also, with this offering,
there came a time where we were able
to see the convergence
that I'm gonna talk about
in a little bit, right?
So the scientists were
coming in and saying,
I need HPC clusters, I need them now.
I can't wait for the
on-prem queues, right?
I can't wait to do my R&D
because I wanted to get that done now.
We're trying to go operational
in XYZ year, right, or month.
And so being able to have
this capacity and capability
was a big success at NOAA.
We have a couple of
use cases to talk about
in that perspective, right?
The biggest one and the same one
that David was talking
about earlier on-prem
is the hurricane analysis
and forecast system.
And we've ran this a
couple of years in AWS,
real time, during the hurricane season.
Real time, hurricane season,
a 21-member ensemble
would run twice a day.
The output of that data
was exported to S3,
shared with scientists
so they can collaborate
and they can look at that data
and see where you need refinements,
and this helped to help
them solve problems
and even improve the
model over time, right?
Without waiting again for when
they can run these on-prem
as well as when they can get the analysis
that they need done
after those runs, right?
We ran 399 hpc6a.48xlarge at that time
on those twice a day,
during those twice-a-day lab results
and lab runs that we was running as well.
And this was beneficial when
they were doing a test bed
and trying to analyze, in real time,
the data that was coming
out of the models, right?
Another good,
or I should say great
case study that came up
was what we call RRFS, the
Rapid Refresh Forecast System.
Now my understanding is RRFS
is slated to go operational in 2026.
And the reason,
and one of the reasons why
they've been able to do so
is because they were able to
leverage AWS to run the model.
Again, this too was an ensemble run
that they ran consistently during the day.
Again, they standardized
on the Lustre file system,
giving that high throughput.
They standardized on the
purpose-built HPC instances again.
And they also, again,
exported the data from those models
to AWS Open Data so that further
analysis and understanding
of how the model is run
and how it can be tweaked
can be leveraged as well.
They also found that it ran
15% faster than on-prem,
and it also was 25% better
from a cost-performance standpoint.
But like I said before,
there was a convergence.
So we worked through a few years
with the HPC-as-a-Service offering,
and then we found something interesting.
The scientists and researchers were like,
we want access to Jupyter Notebooks.
We want access to AI-ML services.
We also need to have the capability
to analyze large data sets
that's outputted from these models.
So we've seen the convergence
from using the big,
tightly-coupled HPC clusters
to AI-ML service within
this particular offering.
Now while we was enabling
that, we were like, why?
And David explained it earlier.
We didn't know early on why is it so,
but we figured it out later,
is that we were seeing the convergence
into AI weather prediction coming.
So David talked about earlier
with the traditional numerical
weather prediction models.
These are physical based.
They take the data from the
sensors, from the buoys,
from the satellites, and they
take that observation data
and they running those
computations on a supercomputer
on-prem to get the
analysis and the forecast
and the re-analysis.
With AI weather prediction, though,
it's slightly different,
in the sense that we have
the training of the data
using that numerical
weather data output, right?
And then there's inference
that happens with that data,
with that training data
that we have there.
So,
what's astounding to me,
and when I looked at it,
is that from a SageMaker Jupyter Notebook,
in minutes instead of hours,
your scientists and your
researchers are able
to do those weather forecasts
and they get the output and
the data that they need.
This democratizes weather prediction.
We have the challenges that
David talked about earlier.
Now we got more data coming in!
I think it's a good problem to have.
But also, we can see
how this conversion is also
helping us to solve problems
and do other scientific advancements
with AI weather prediction,
because this is a single GPU
instance that I'm using here
or that I'm showing here on this slide
instead of a tightly-coupled
large HPC cluster, right?
David talked about the
models that's available
with NOAA and they're working on.
These are some other
models that are out there.
FourCastNet, Pangu-Weather,
GraphCast, Aurora.
All can be ran on AWS
with a single GPU, or if it's an ensemble,
like David was talking about earlier,
you're essentially gonna be
looking at several GPUs there.
But the idea here is, again,
from a Jupyter Notebook,
you could run AI weather prediction
in minutes instead of hours.
To prove that, because the
proof is in the pudding,
I'm a technologist, I'm
not a scientist, right?
But I was able to run this
FourCastNetv2 Small AI Model.
What you see here is Hurricane Helene
coming through Florida
into North Carolina.
And you can see my name up there.
That's my notebook that's running there
based off of some code that I found,
open source and available out there.
So even myself as a technologist
is able to do these runs.
Just imagine this researchers
and scientists having this capability
to be able to run these, at will,
with the capacity that they need
and the compute options that they need
available in the cloud.
And so with that, Mickey's gonna come up
and talk about the future of HPC and AI.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Rayette.
So you heard a great case
study from our colleague
from National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration.
Some great examples of
the use of supercomputing
to solve their mission issues
and to get to the right mission outcomes
that they're looking at.
And then you heard from Rayette about
how AWS is powering that infrastructure
and providing support
to National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration.
So what does the future
of HPC and AI look like?
We at AWS believe it is bright.
And if you are not aware
of this, about a week ago,
we announced $50 billion in
infrastructure investment
to build new AI and supercomputer centers
for the US government.
This $50 billion investment
is comparable to 1.3
gigawatts in compute capacity.
And this will serve the missions
of various government agencies,
including those
that have their workloads
in the US GovCloud,
in our secret regions, in
our top-secret regions,
as well as across all
data classifications.
Now this investment is based
on real-world innovation
that we've been seeing, our customers
like National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration,
as well as many other
agencies demonstrate.
So what I wanted to do
was kind of take you
through a couple of these examples
just to kind of spur the innovation.
So first of all, we have
a partner called S2 Labs
and they do subsurface mapping.
What does subsurface mapping mean?
Basically, it means that
without doing any excavation,
you're trying to figure out
what is buried underground.
Could be an infrastructure,
could be cables,
could be pipelines, could
be construction material,
but you have to figure out
what it is underground,
especially when you cannot do excavation.
So in 2004, there was Hurricane Ivan.
Anybody remembers that?
Okay.
So Hurricane Ivan actually
destroyed an offshore oil rink
and all the critical
infrastructure fell into the ocean
and it was buried under
meters of sediment.
Now it took 18 years of trials,
using traditional acoustic methods,
to try to figure out where
that infrastructure was buried
because it was hazardous waste as well.
But there was no success.
Until S2 Labs
used deep learning
and applied physics and inferencing
along with supercomputing-grade APIs
to try to solve that problem.
And they were able to do that
with unprecedented clarity.
So much so that they developed a workflow
that can actually map
an area of the size of 400
meters by 400 meters by 60 meters
in under five seconds.
That's 29 and a half football fields.
So the key innovation here is
that this has applicability
in many, many different industries.
Oil and gas is one,
energy, utility, urban development,
construction safety,
as well as many others.
So this is exactly a great
example of what we're seeing
for the convergence of HPC and AI
and the results it's delivering.
Let's look at one more example.
Now many of you may have encountered
some challenges when you're trying
to provide decision-making that involves
multiple expert teams
that need to come together and collaborate
and then provide some kind of an analysis.
This happens a lot in
the engineering domain,
in the science domain,
even in the financial services domain
where you're trying to
approve a loan, for example.
So we have a partner called Synera,
which is a process automation company,
and they worked on a domain of engineering
where in order to provide
a request for quotation
for an engineering component
that is actually comprised
of many, many other components
that need to be assembled together,
each one of which has to be monitored
and for which the information
needs to be provided
by a different engineering expert,
and all that information
needs to be synthesized.
And they wanted to try to model that
and create a solution for that
using HPC performance-grade
APIs as well as AI-ML.
So they developed a solution
based on Amazon Bedrock,
EC2 instances running on Nvidia,
as well as additional
AI-ML-based inferencing.
And what they were able to do was
take this assembly of
complex engineering parts
from multiple different experts,
take all of their expertise,
and run a multi-agent AI system
that gathers this information,
reasons through it,
and then provides the result,
from three weeks to several minutes now.
Again, you know, great example of how
we applied with our
partner HPC supercomputing
to solve a very, very complex problem.
So these two are just
scratching the surface.
There are many, many areas of innovation
that are possible with this
convergence of HPC and AI-ML,
and certainly with the
investment that we are making,
especially for the US government,
we see that this will become
more advanced in the future as well.
So let me just do a quick recap.
You know, we started about talking,
talking about the convergence
of HPC and AI-ML in the cloud.
We talked about, hey, back in 2023,
there's about $37 billion
worth of market for HPC.
We see this progressing quite
rapidly, 24% growth in 2024.
And then by 2029,
the analysts are telling us
that the conversion market,
it's gonna be about $49 billion.
Then we had David come up and
talk about NOAA's mission.
It's not just about forecasting.
Remember that, right?
They do so many other things
which are extremely important.
And then we had Rayette
come and talk about
the infrastructure, the
compute, the capacity,
and the architecture that is
supporting NOAA's mission.
So we hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you very much for your time.
(audience applauding)